all right um one of the things that we
do is we always use the angle so take
the body at an angle take the body at an
angle those are your back position at
the
angle and then when you go forward take
the body at an
angle take the body at an
angle what we don't do
is try to bend the body in
half bend the body in half or try to
lift this way even on koshen net if you
pay attention once you add the spiring
geometry he's at an angle okay I don't I
don't try to go
here and try to pick that
up there's always some angle he starts
to push there's my
angle that that angle that we used
there he comes in there's my angle right
there you can see it's going into that
same in that case your left inward front
inward position okay so if I take
tension
net I'm not going to go here and bend
him backwards and and then
throw I'm going to tilt
him into that angle right
here going to tilt him into that
angle if I
do
uh you're going to see the same thing
I'm going to tilt him into that
angle I'm not going to bend him
backwards bodies that are attacking you
are automatically if so facto engaged in
the center they do not Bend in the
center only scaredy choreograph UK has
Bend in the center so if he locks his
Center
right I'm not going to bend this but I
sure can't tilt
it because easier to tilt do you
understand
okay so it doesn't it doesn't matter
what the technique is and you can kind
of see it more
easily on the
inward back position but it's the same
on the outward back position okay so K
hole comes
around and now that
happens with this adhesion point this
adhesion
point it's not that my elbow hits him in
the face or he doesn't want to get H in
the face so he backs up and bends over
you
understand so I get this adhesion point
and that adhesion Point tilts
him you see that tilt
so same thing if he is asocially violent
the center will be automatically engaged
it will not Bend so if he locked his
Center consciously now lock it I cannot
bend him but I sure as heck can tilt
him do you
understand okay
so how do we tilt him
watch his head going back to teni net
his head is going to make contact with
my arm I use the adhesion to do this to
his
head go slower his head's going to come
forward under around all the way around
and there it is right
there so watch I doing that in tension
nugget boom I bring it around
and then into the tilt on
nugget contact I bring It Forward around
come
[Music]
forward I go slow I want you to go with
me so I don't I they can see it if I go
fast they're not going to see it okay so
one rock around
in and basically he's going War around
back and into it okay now I have to do
that with C hle bring him into here
Bo and do it with one arm in this side
boom so if you're too far away and
there's none of that it's not going to
work into your arm then my arm takes
over my upper arm don't use your grip to
control his
body just like I'm here I use his grip
to bring his head into contact with the
arm and now I'm not using the grips I
changed my adhesion point so if he lets
go it doesn't
matter do you understand it's no
different than if for fighting
sideways right and I'm here I'm going to
check right and come in I'm bypassing
the wrist to attack the head I'm not
going to keep holding this and do that I
bypass oh and I'm
in so use the grip to get to this
adhesion point then the grips are not
important
so same thing
here that's it the grip is now not
important I'm using this adhesion
Point
Bo do not Bend him backwards no no no
that means you have you have to let him
come forward first he has to go
forward then
around not here you're coming
in contact ignore the grip adhesion on
the upper
arm okay leave out the base displacement
so we just work on that go all right so
that that's what I'm doing and if I if I
do it
right then you're going to see that
before my arm goes that way he's already
going that
way you
see it's not that I'm here and I go and
then I push
him same thing here it's not that I'm
here and I throw him and I accelerate
him backwards he's already once I get
that adhesion Point again the grips are
now irrelevant so we can show let's go
when I do the turn he's already going
that way you see that got it okay
so
boom
you should I want you to stop
here don't go past your shoulder and he
should be going backwards okay
try so that's what I'm doing with my IID
heian okay uh but there is a pattern
that that you're make it there is a
pattern that you're make it
hold this one this one this one okay so
let's say he's doing some downward stri
to my head that's the
pattern that's the pattern
boom okay or I want to hit him under the
chin it's the pattern that I'm using
okay so pay attention it's not a
free-for-all we're doing G do so my palm
is going to go up as I'm doing the out
what's going to be the outward spiral
it's going to be the outward
spiral this
one but because I turn it doesn't look
like the outward spiral because I'm
turning on the inside of that movement
okay so this Palm is going to
go there is that upward block that I
just showed you and because I'm going to
enter again and turn again that's where
the Palm up comes
from by entering to the other side of
this hand
because I'm going to attack his base
here so keep your stuff spinning your
arm your wrist
rotating don't go turn the camera don't
go
here keep rotating into it upward block
now don't go
here keep rotating that hand
get on into the
upward step to the other side of it and
it'll end up Palm
up so I don't want to go Palm up Palm up
Palm up there's no rotation in that arm
do you see that and you end up with it
cosmetically Palm up Palm up Palm up
Palm up up all your Delta
rotate the
hand and because I'm moving in circles
in relation to that spiral that's how
the hand looks like what you're seeing
okay W here it is pop that's where that
is and now I move to the other side of
my
hand and it'll be Palm
up
okay let us get the hand pattern the
hand pattern okay okay so that is my
pattern that is the kazushi right there
and all all I
needed was that you see that's all you
need even stop that'll be enough but
remember the inertia is having him go
this way you
remember that little tilt is all I need
that is kazushi and here's where I would
come in and displace his base very much
like
aatos so his base is weak and that's
where I displace his
base and that will help him go into that
kazushi Yang you see it makes his head
go that way okay so that's all I want I
want his body to be going the other
direction and now he's light and that's
where I can displace
base you understand different from I'm
here I shove them backwards and then I
accelerate here that's Yang on
yang I am instead creating Yin energy
going this
way and what is my arm doing
then an i adhesion on him it's not
shoving him
down as his head goes into the kazushi
that you see
here my arm follows his head as it just
did that
patter until he falls off my arm you
understand it's not here and I'm the one
shoving him down yes my arm is touching
him but it's not what's pushing
him this energy had going
backwards and I stayed up with
it that and I stay up with
that
that's where we bring
in B displacement if your R can do
it if they can't do it you'll just come
a
little not as
sharp but the arm doesn't do anything
different it stays with him it does not
throw
him stays with him do not throw him he
should not need to be
accelerated try it
again so when he's
pushing and I'm ground vectoring all
this is very relaxed very very soft but
he can't push he can't push it
okay uh it's not it's not this it's not
this it's not tension okay it's not this
hyper
flection well likewise when you see the
yin movement the yin
movement it's not uh
weak so if he wants to push it really
fast
got me so I'm going to yield but he
can't he can't push it do you see he
can't he can't push it at any degree
past what I want him to do you
understand same way he still can't he
still can't push it because of I'm just
ground vectoring that that hammer still
can't push it okay it's not that I just
get out of the way you see that
difference
which is why if he's pulling
me you if you're if your go-to Yin
movement was go soft and get out of the
way you're never going to get the
technique but if you had that internal C
it doesn't matter it'll make it easier
because of how much energy he's adding
to the yin movement in his pulling of it
it generates more energy at the contact
point and the IE adhesion becomes more
intense
and doesn't require me to do all the
centrifical energy generating do you got
that so don't go that's not
it that's not it it's not dead it's not
a wet
noodle just
like extension separation is not tension
yielding and communion is not
weakness there is a space that I keep
internally even though I'm yielded even
you know I'm doing all Yin
movements it is not just he pushes and I
get out of the way so keep your shape
inside inside here it goes inside so
same same thing here let's say he wants
to pull down on it if it's weak he's
going to get me here I pull if he pulls
on it makes him move you see that cuz
he's pulling himself off his face and
that'll make the turn easier here for
me because I'm
grounded
here
oh okay let's try it